is it true that covet cannot be driven
extinct due to animal reservoirs
which is a
excuse me a reference to this finding
that came out sometime this week
that some crazy huge number like 30 to
40 percent of whitetail deer in the u.s
um well it was from certain sample
populations but they extrapolated to the
us are they not uh there's definitely an
implication but um but let's just have
tested positive for for antibodies there
it is
well so let's let's talk about this
first of all there is a lot of panic
over the fact that lots of creatures
have tested positive for sars kovi too i
wouldn't worry about most of them okay
so we've had and we've had it
transmitted to
big cats we've had it transmitted to
both cats and dogs
domestic cats we've had it transmitted
to um apes in the zoo basically zoo
animals and domesticated creatures have
caught it but there's a big difference
between catching it and being able to
transmit it to another creature like
within your species and then another
difference between that and being able
to transmit it back to a human which
that last step is actually the most
likely in some sense if it caught it
from a human i would say so yes
but that said
we really are not guaranteed we really
only have two species in which we have
seen something that
looks like
human disease right the ability to
transmit it readily etc and those are
minks and ferrets right and one instance
literally a single individual mink that
has been found in the wild with the
disease i believe with the virus itself
not just the antibodies so i'm not 100
sure of that but in any case otherwise
it's farms right and pet fairies farms
and the mink farms and pet farts and the
mink that was found with it was near a
farm so it's not an independent thing so
is sars kobe 2 out there in some way in
animal reservoirs that prevents us from
driving it extinct yeah maybe
right we got minks and ferrets which we
can deal with because they're in farms
we've got lots of individual cases where
an animal has picked it up and it hasn't
circulated in the population those
aren't serious yet they could certainly
become serious but they aren't um
continues to evolve
right the virus continues to evolve and
manifest differently right and i should
point out that the mink ferret thing
is very likely related to the very
probable lab leak right and the point is
ferrets would likely have been a study
subject in gain of function research it
may have been passaged through ferrets
because their ace2 receptor is very much
like ours so
in any case yes
and minks and ferrets are close
relatives yes and they're so the ace2
receptors of the
uh mustelids are minx mustangs yeah of
that whole that clade of mammals um is
all very similar to humans that's why
they are model organisms used in things
like unit function experiments yep and
we should be looking at other closely
related critters uh skunks are a
possibility but
um
they're just outside so it's an
arbitrary distinction they used to be
mysterious and now they've been moved
but they haven't gotten it's the stripes
isn't it they're excluded on the basis
of the stripes i couldn't say no
that's not how systemics work but okay
let's get back to the deer
when i first heard about this study on a
deer i thought oh this is the worst
conceivable news because
this really does look like a widespread
epidemic within white-tailed deer in
which case there's there is no chance of
eradicating the virus
i wouldn't say that but i would say it
makes it just got
much
harder yeah um
that said
so my first thought was
worst possible news my second thought
was
i'm not even sure i believe that this is
true
and i thought maybe this was the result
of a coronavirus that circulates in deer
that has resulted in antibodies that are
triggering the test but it's not really
a new thing okay nope
the study was better than that it
definitely tested samples from after the
cobia pandemic and before the covered
pandemic and with a couple of exceptions
that are likely to be false positives
the triggering is all post-pandemic
so it does look like something now is
the antibody
test detecting
animals that are or have been infected
and have not had disease there's still
something strange about this did
was there
a
non-symptomatic or so lightly
symptomatic pandemic in deer that got a
foothold so quickly from human infection
something is not entirely seems not
entirely likely about this but
possible
uh is it possible the antibodies
are reacting to something coveted like
in the environment without the infection
that seems unlikely that so many would
trigger a test so anyway let's just say
worst case scenario is that this
actually represents
sars kobe 2 infecting populations of
deer and the deer are giving it to each
other enough that we can detect it in a
large fraction of something like 40 of
samples in the michigan population
um
does that mean we're stuck with sars
kobe 2
forever uh it could mean that
on the other hand i would say we are
stuck with rabies
right yeah but
we have rabies well under control in the
western world
right
yeah it is both well under control and
for those of us who do work that puts us
at risk of a high risk of exposure there
are vaccines there are vaccines and we
have a program for dealing with the
human interface with animals that can
carry rabies yeah and so anyway every so
often somebody dies of rabies right but
if every so often somebody died of covid
um that would be
a very tiny harm compared to a
uncontrolled circulating
pandemic so so i do think we need to
start drawing a cleaner line between can
we drive it absolutely extinct which
would be wonderful i'm not convinced
that if it's in white-tailed deer
circulating that it's beyond the
possibility right in fact
uh there are a lot of ways that could go
but uh but anyway even even if we found
if we drive if we drove it out of the
human population and it remained in the
deer population there are various things
there are various levels of commitment
that we could put to the problem and
address it
but even if we didn't
if the point was well we're kind of
stuck with it because it's permanently
in the deer and we decide we can't do
anything about that
then the answer is well maybe this could
be so well managed like rabies that it
is effectively not in the human
population right that the interactions
with it are so rare that it's
effectively not uh
not circulating oh i think that's
interesting yeah because rabies remains
much more of a problem for some other
species than it does for us
yeah
yeah um so anyway i would say look i
still i still have seen nothing that
says it can't be driven it's extinct if
the deer studies it sounds like you
you're still agnostic but you're leaning
towards that deer study
seems to likely be
my first
thought was it's going to be flawed and
the flaw will be easy to spot and that's
not what i saw yeah your study looks
well done okay that's so more likely but
there's still something odd about the
story so this thing
came to
north america in early 2020
must have leapt to deer very quickly
evolved enough capacity to move between
them and now a higher percentage of deer
than humans have been exposed right it's
it
i still will not be surprised if there's
something wrong here but i don't i is
there is nothing in the paper that
indicates a poorly done study fair
enough
[Music]